-Guys, I know a lot of people
who find math boring.
Yeah.
Well, we've updated math
to make the equations more
about stuff you can relate to.
It's time for
"Popular Mathematics."
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ Popular ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
-Such a good song.
-That's such a catchy tune.
Let's take a look
at our first equation here.
If you take a pair of Crocs,
plus getting too close
to a campfire,
it equals Yeezys.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-So, yeah that's how it works.
Next up, if you take MMA
plus COVID safety,
it equals "Mortal Kombat."
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I can even -- I feel myself
getting smarter
as I'm doing these equations.
-You can visualize them, too.
-Yes. If you take Dr. Fauci --
-Yep.
-...plus 20 decibels,
plus rubbing a balloon
on your head,
it equals Bernie Sanders.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Math is fun again.
-It's fun!
-Math is fun again,
and "The Tonight Show"
helped make it that way.
Here's another one.
If you take three NASCAR races,
plus three "Rambo" sequels,
plus three tons of TNT,
minus hair,
it equals "Fast & Furious 9."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's true. Numbers
-Here is another one.
Dark red.
-Yeah.
-Plus the president.
-Mm-hmm.
-Plus "MMMBop"...
equals Scarlett Johansson.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a thinker.
That's a thinker.
-Somebody just walked out.
-Are you serious?
-Yeah.
Somebody just stood up.
-Said "That's it."
-"That's it. That's it."
They stood up,
and they walked out.
"That's it, I can take no more!"
-"That is not my kind of humor."
-"Good day to you, sir!"
-Scarlett Jo-hansson.
-That's right.
"Good day to you, sir."
-[ Chuckles ]
"I didn't pay money for this."
-I should audition for the new
"Downton Abbey" movie.
-You should. It's coming out.
-Right?
-They're shooting it, yeah.
-They're filming it now.
-Yeah.
-I just want to come in and go,
"Good day to you, sir."
-And then walk out
with gloves in your --
-And then -- Well, I should
have gloves in my hand,
or I should be wearing gloves.
-Right.
-And then someone insults me.
-And I go, "Good day
to you, sir."
And then they're leaving,
and they insult me again.
And I go, "Good day
to you, sir."
And then they insult me
one more time and belittle me.
-Right. Right.
-I go...
[Voice shaking]
"Good day to you, sir!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Slap! ]
-And then you put the glove
back on.
-Yeah.
-That's a class move.
That's a class move.
Oh, you button it.
Oh, my God.
That glove has buttons.
Oh wait, a zipper.
It's a zipper glove
with buttons.
Oh, and it's fold-over?
Oh, my God.
It's got Velcro.
Oh, and a crank
and a crank and a crank.
[ Laughter ]
-"Good day to you, sir!"
-Out!
-[ Chuckles ]
That's another good one.
"Out!"
"Out."
I'll give you three different --
-Yeah, you get three different
things on everything.
That's what makes you
such a great actor.
-Thank you, man.
I appreciate it.
-Yeah.
-"Out!"
-Now you're scared.
Do -- You're scared.
-"Out."
-Now you're angry.
-"Out!"
-Now you're trepidation --
you have trepidation --
you're trepidatious.
-"Out?"
[ Laughter ]
Here's another one here.
Harry Styles.
-Yeah.
-Plus a ceramics wheel
equals Harry potter.
-Oh.
-See, you understand?
-Yeah, that's mathematics.
Popular.
-Up next,
if you take Ted Danson.
-Ted Danson.
-Plus Tom Selleck.
-Mm-hmm.
-Plus Steve Guttenberg,
plus Da Baby,
equals three men and Da Baby.
[ Laughter ]
They should make that.
-Come on!
-They should make that.
-Come on.
-Starting filming tomorrow.
-"Three Men and Da Baby."
Finally, if you take
getting a vaccine,
plus The Rock,
plus "Nash Bridges,"
plus the Prime Minister
of the U.K., it equals
Johnson & Johnson & Johnson
& Johnson & Johnson.
That's all the time we have for
"Popular Mathematics."